hello it's so good to be here I wanted
to not only welcome you to the webinar
but welcome David it's so nice to have
you here and joining mentoring David um
has been nearly two decades working with
different entrepreneurial ventures he
was a deep love for startup his
backgrounds not just in LA but also
certainly adventure and a little known
fact about David is that he is an
executive producer at heart producing
experiences sort of more than things and
so this idea being a storyteller lives
deep in his blood to start off I wanted
to ask you what is a six word story
about you that would describe you I keep
changing my mind what the story will be
you know the simplest is escape the law
became venture capitalist that's but but
that seems to focused on the specifics
of you know the of our of my path I
think maybe better yet is maniacally
focused on helping others grow nice I I
went for relentlessly planning for
spontaneity and inspiration there you go
so what I wanted to do is just start off
with a little bit of grounding around
story David and I have been playing
around with this idea of storytelling
for gosh at least the last couple years
but I also teach a few classes on it and
it's it's helpful to sort of set the
stage for the webinar first our our main
goal here is to get you to think about
story as an asset for your business and
so if we do nothing else in the next 45
minutes or so it would be to think of
story as an asset so many of us I think
think of data facts and figures as the
most important things to focus on when
driving business and what I think we
would contend is that equally important
is your story your store and there's
there's at least four important stories
that every business person needs to have
in their portfolio we'll talk about
those
I think the other thing that we hope you
get out of it is to
think about how do you emotionally
connect with your audience and your
audience could be board members it could
be venture capitalists that might invest
in you it might be a talented team and
it might be your customers so as you as
you go through this webinar I think a
little bit about what is the most
important audience to keep in mind to as
you develop your story what we're gonna
hope to do is spark a few ideas of how
you can create your own stories so the
way that this webinar will kind of flow
is we'll do a brief introduction and
then I'm going to talk to David about
some of his experiences with story
particularly from his vantage point
we'll hone in on a few different stories
one is the story to connect you to your
audience
to build your team an influencer culture
to build your brand in the long run and
to spur innovation the other thing I'm
going to mention is that will will
divide this webinar bit to three parts
what why stories are important in
business we'll dive into these four
discrete stories and then we'll turn it
over to you and pull in some QA so let
me just set the stage we're gonna define
story here as a connected series of
events with a beginning a middle and an
end
so it has a specific structure you can
think of it as a journey that moves the
listener and when the listener goes on
that journey and and you finish the
story they somehow feel different they
are transformed and one of the reasons
they're transformed is the protagonist
in the journey is also transformed so
stories are all around us there's some
studies that have shown that in fact 65%
of our daily conversations are made up
of personal stories and gossip alone so
just think about that we've got 65% of
our day-to-day life being filled with
small anecdotes and gossip and story
suggesting that as we become
storytellers and understand the power of
story we might be able to influence the
nature and the outcome of those
conversations I'd say that my I bet your
mind is closer to 80 yeah
yours is insane where's your story
people and as you as you find the power
of you know connecting people with these
ideas you end up using it as a tool for
everything and I certainly use it with
my children I'd certainly use it in
business and a sitting in board meeting
so I think that story as you understand
its power becomes more and more a part
of your toolkit yeah so I'm so
interested in that how would you say at
least as you started to take on this
frame how can you give us a few examples
of when you use story either at home or
in business well for sure I mean that
the reality is that so I'm as a venture
capitalist one of the things I do all
the time is go to board meetings and
board meetings to a certain degree are
these incredibly dull lets tell you
where we are in the business people
present and and as an investor I'm
trying to help the company move along
trying to give my perspective and so you
have two choices you can say I really
think you should do X and maybe they
think by virtue of the fact that you've
invested in them that they'll do those
things but the far more effective thing
is to say you know I've seen this in the
past I've seen this I've seen this
problem in the past and and so here's
how it works you know here's what here's
how it here's here are the instances in
which it's been powerful or you've
affected change or you have really
gotten burnt if you continue doing this
thing and by telling that tale by saying
in these other contexts here's what I've
seen people naturally connect themselves
to that circumstance and say oh wow
let's not do that so I was on a call
just yesterday company that's raising
money and they're talking to a set of
different investors and each investor
has a different characteristic and one
of them is a very new investor very new
to the business trying to be very
technical and I said you know I've seen
this sort of investor before and here's
in it's great when things are working
but when it stops working let me tell
you what happens you know and here's the
experience and so you should project
this sort of experience on this you know
this group of investors in it chain it
was like oh okay that's that's an
interesting perspective
and so what you're trying to do is
you're trying to give your audience 2+2
so they say 4 right and the process of
giving them 2+2 instead of 4 allows them
to feel like they're part of the
solution that they are part of the aha
and then when research shows that when
people make that inference they feel
more closely connected to the solution
rather than just hearing it from you and
it's funny at one point in this exact
same call I was quite dictatorial I was
a table you need to you know this is
what I think and you it cetera and it
was so ineffective and in the end I said
you know I and luckily this is a group
of people have worked with me a long
time and in the end I said listen you
guys know that I'm just stating this
really strongly but that's not a
conclusion it's just a suggestion
yeah right to try and back off of that I
just gave you four it's like no no no
time with us 2+2 I swear and absolutely
for a parenting perspective the
dictatorial approach only works for so
long so then as a tool you only have
stories to persuade one of the biggest
misconceptions and I'm sure you've seen
this is that most people think that
stories are this big epic thing right
their movies their Broadway shows and
yet stories can be really small they can
be something as simple as four or six
words they could be a tweet they could
be just a three-minute video one-minute
video I'm curious in your experience are
there any short stories that have come
across your path where you thought wow
that short story fundamentally change
the way I thought about this startup and
it wasn't this big long epic thing it
was just a short anecdote story or
narrative well it's interesting you know
I've met with an amazing entrepreneur
the other day and the first presentation
that this entrepreneur did focused on
the entrepreneur and so that you know
just the thumbnail of this of this
person's experience was enough to make
us think holy this person is
unbelievable like how you know because
we had all lived these very you know
sort of privileged lie
of going to in seven having running
water and having electricity whatever
and this was an entrepreneur who said
well I grew up in a home that had no
electricity and our closest town was a
hundred miles away and yet he's been a
wildly successful technology
entrepreneur and that just is
electrifying yeah that in and of itself
is electrifying right so you're falling
in love with a protagonist like you feel
like you know that person you see there
you can imagine their hurdles their
struggles and you surmounted that
absolutely and I'd say that the truth is
and I'm tested on this all the time
because what happens is I've invested in
a dozen companies and people say okay
what are you invested in right well I'm
not gonna it's not gonna be 20 minutes
per company right I have about four
seconds per company often times the
context for these conversations is I'll
be at a a party or a business gathering
and people say so what have you invested
in and I have a very short period of
time to describe in a hopefully
hopefully very compelling way these
portfolio of companies so I've invested
in you know Rocket Lawyer which is
helping small and medium businesses
bring their get the legal resources to
transform their businesses right if it's
seven sentences you go huh
I really didn't care that much about
Rocket Lawyer oh it's transforming SMB
business with legal resources great you
know that's and so often time to having
that capacity to really create that you
know that emotional relationship between
a business problem at solution and is
you know is really powerful great so
let's dive into four different types of
stories specifically how storytelling
can contribute to a successful pitch the
second type of story that we should all
have in our portfolio is the story that
really inspires your team that makes
high talent people want to come join
your team the third is how do you really
tell a story that connects to your
customer and closes the sale so many
times people think that stories are sort
of a softer approach and yet research
shows that it actually allows customers
to feel closer to the brand and closes
sales and the fourth story is this one
about spurring growth and innovation so
so let's start off with one that's in
your wheelhouse a story that seals the
deal that a entrepreneur is trying to
pitch to a venture capitalist or an
investor any examples come to mind well
every pitch has to be a story right I
mean any anyone who thinks that they're
pitching a business and it's not about
creating this you know this excitement
and engagement is is gonna fail right
and I often describe my own process as I
spend an hour you're presenting your
company we have a conversation and then
you leave and then that night I go to
bed and if I lie down in bed and I think
about your business then we're on to
something I might actually fund you well
I'm probably not gonna be lying down in
bed thinking to myself wow they're grown
from 12 to 24 hundred customers but I
might think in my head oh wow I didn't
realize that it was such a big problem
the transfer of you know foreign
exchange across markets and here's how
they've transformed that business right
and so it's creating that story that
here is a problem it's a real problem
oftentimes it's put in the context of a
real company a real individual and here
is how we've solved that problem here is
what we here's why we think this is
eight and engaging and clever solution
that that that helps lots of people lots
of businesses those are the things where
you leave and think okay that's
something that I think is compelling and
has scale and an entrepreneur who
understands how to motivate people so so
in every instance when I'm pitching on a
business it's a story first it's the
story of the entrepreneur and then it's
the story of how they came to what
they're building and in fact even the
team question right the first thing I
asked you when you say and here's my VP
of engine
and here's my co-founder whatever is
how'd you meet how do you because a
collection of people is way less
interesting than a collection of you
know connected people who are friends or
coworkers or share a fanaticism for
Bitcoin or all of these things so
literally in every instance there has to
be some connective tissue that leads you
to believe that there's something bigger
to this than the collective parts and so
just to recap think about why David
would be thinking about you lying in bed
just just wanted to recap the the big
idea there the other two key insights
there is that your personal story is so
important they you know essentially
we're looking at ourselves as potential
protagonists or characters in a story
and and people get excited about
investing in and participating and
people they believe in protagonists that
are compelling that are relentless that
are passionate and so I think taking
that perspective into account as you're
developing your pitch is so important
you know what is compelling about you
and your story so here's a great just to
hit on that a little bit we have one
entrepreneur who went left college and
joined the women's NBA and played you
know was a professional basketball
player and described the ways in which
that experience of going from high
school to college ball to professional
ball hadn't affected her thinking about
team building and winning and all of
that stuff in the same way that when
we're pitched by Israeli entrepreneurs
who have all served in the military they
can all tell you the ways in which their
military service have impacted the way
they're thinking about the business
they're creating and to the point where
we can tell you within five minutes
which thing you did in the military we
know coming in oh you were a fighter
pilot yeah oh you were in the
Intelligence Agency right because it's
so entwined with what you're building
and how you'll build it oh it's a great
example I there's a there's an
entrepreneur that I admire a lot her
name is Shraddha
she she built a start-up just in the
last three years which is blossomed and
it's because of story so she was a
journalist etc and she was interviewing
entrepreneurs and instead of basically
taking down facts and figures of how
they grew their company from 12 to 24
percent etc she told she asked them
their stories and entrepreneurs love to
tell their story by and large and so she
would collect those stories and then she
created a repository for those stories
and as a result of taking that very
human centered approach of listening to
their stories she was able to grow her
own organization significantly to the
point that the data that she supports
and how many people she supports over
12,000 entrepreneurs in the last couple
years now tell their stories on her
platform I think it's just been amazing
so let's talk about the second type of
story this idea of a story we're calling
it the wiki of your organization a story
that works as an internal fulcrum which
your team can stress-test business
decisions and this is something that
James Backhouse a brilliant storyteller
himself in fact the managing editor or
at Twitter sort of describes as one of
the more important stories and it really
informs your role the team's role and
your company's role and we have a couple
of examples on this slide share but I'm
intrigued by this idea that every
organization should be able to tell a
four or six word story about themselves
just like how we introduced ourselves
you know Google's is really simple it
launched with you know do no evil three
word story highly efficient are there
are there are there ventures within your
portfolio where you can just nail you
know the forward story so that you know
just you know lie in bed thinking about
this entrepreneur and why you might want
to invest in him and her but their story
is so clear and so simple for sure i've
so i've funded this one entrepreneur
twice a guy named Renee lesser and
Renee's first company was called pay
cycle and he was creating an online
payroll company and I remember people
saying well why are you excited about
payroll you know
payroll is like the most boring and long
existing thing ever but Rene had come
from a family his parents had been pay
up had run a payroll company yet built
payroll within and to it he really
believed in payroll but the thing that
he came to understand was that by taking
payroll and bringing it online you would
enable a whole lot of a whole lot of
power to the small business owner right
to allow them more flexibility to
control their own money to control their
own destiny and so he looked at and said
this is how I'm gonna help small
business owners I'm gonna make their
lives better this isn't about making
money it isn't about a technical
solution it's about giving flexibility
back to small business owners whose
lives are very hectic and challenged so
pay cycle turned out to be a great
business it was ultimately sold to
intuit for a lot of money and then he
thought well what's the next problem and
you know we've solved payroll what's the
next problem in the next problem that
he's had that he went on to solve is
this problem of how do you manage your
money as a small business owner how do
you manage who you're paying and how
you're being paid and so he has a new
company called bill comm when bill comm
is is about accounts payable and
receivable and electronic payments but
to the company it is about creating a
paperless experience to empower small
businesses it's about allowing small
business owners to understand their
finances in a way that makes their lives
easier and makes their businesses better
its disagree I mean that's such a great
example I think I've also like Adobe
unleashing creativity in the world or HP
all around invents you know the core
story of HP for example the two guys in
a garage in Silicon Valley creating an
innovation that core founding story
disproportionately outweighs any other
thing that HP could do in terms of
acquiring top talent and really
cementing why why we're here i I think
there's also
makes it really clear not just why the
team is together but it it helps make
decision-making faster because when
everyone internally is on the same page
believes the same story they can make
rapid decisions they can move much more
quickly with more limited marketing
funds because the story is clear and if
you think of you know for example
Genentech you know the story there is in
business for life you know really to
create life and when Roche took over
many people I talked to really said that
this you know they're doing the same
thing internally at Genentech that they
were before but the story is different
now we're a part of Roche and so I think
the other thing you need to keep in mind
when you think of these internal stories
the founding story the growth story is
to what degree is it coherent you know
and all of the stories that come out of
the organization out of the team
do they somehow create a through-line a
consistent a consistent story across
each of these sort of steps that they go
through I heard this tale when Yahoo was
having a lot of challenges they were
going through challenges and and so they
said about trying to create a mission
statement okay listen we need to focus
on what's our mission statement they had
a lot of people involved they went
through a big long process and the
person who was telling me this tale said
that and he was involved in the process
but he knew it had failed when a
particular thing happened and that thing
was a semi-colon said the mission
statement had blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah semicolon blah blah blah blah
I said that's not a mission statement
right and it's exactly your point how do
you know with precision what the issue
what what the focus is when you can't
even you can't even sum it up in a
single sentence it has to has to be
divided so I think that that's
absolutely true and everyone and so
often the message to these companies
that you know these small companies big
companies like is is focus just
understand and focus the rest bolt will
come but if you don't have focus there
isn't a hope right and so this is this
is a great way to create
focus absolutely one of the things that
I find is that many people who actually
start harnessing story do so because the
story flows organically from them but
when you start to use story
strategically for an organization it's
where you have a focus where you have a
goal this is why I'm sharing the story
so I would also underscore this idea of
focus and what your goal is within the
context of story
now the third story that we're
encouraging you to think about is a
story of your customer
I think company is by and large make the
mistake of thinking they're always the
hair out you know they they come on a
white horse and they save the day for
the customer but instead if you really
understand deeply your customer you
understand what their goals are and your
only role is to help them get their goal
and so if you think about Twitter
Facebook and Google as three examples
that have all created websites that are
telling the stories of their customer if
you simply Google Facebook stories or
YouTube stories or Twitter stories you
will come upon a great resource of
essentially a repository or bank on each
of these organizations telling and
helping share the stories of their
customers so just drop drop the the
notion of the brand for a second and
really think about what is the story of
my customer and how am I in a bling bats
torii to get further to enable your
customer to to achieve their own goals
you know a good example of this is
subway here in America there's a
sandwich shop and they can I don't know
if you call it a sandwich shop but we'll
call it a shop friends make it work
their argument several years ago was
simply you know you can actually eat at
Subway and lose weight now they can go
and say you know come here to lose
weight come here to lose weight come
here to lose weight you know till
they're blue in the face no one's gonna
believe that it's sandwich there's
there's there's meat and there's bread
you're not gonna lose weight and not
Jesus therefore the myth that's right
however it turned out Jared
one user of a subway actually did have a
healthy diet of Subway sandwiches and
lost a tremendous amount of weight they
found his story and they spotlighted him
in their marketing campaign to build
their brand and that transformed the way
that users really saw subway much more
effectively than if they told their
story do you have any examples of this
well there's I have a company that is an
enterprise software company so this
business couldn't be harder to describe
in many respects it's a company called
Splunk and what they do is they take the
Machine data from your systems and they
create a platform that sits on top of
them and allows you to extract
information from all of these machine
pieces of machine data so your log files
and your router tables all these things
and so you say well how do you how do
you tell a compelling story about that
what they have done is in in cities
around the world now they have what they
call Splunk live experiences where they
bring in their customers and their
customers tell how they're using Splunk
to create value so a customer will sit
down and say you know we have one
customer that has manages huge
facilities lots and lots of buildings
and they've taken all the sensor data
from all of their buildings put it into
this Splunk engine and had been able to
figure out how to save a huge amount of
money in electricity in operations
inefficiency so they tell this telling
people go huh that's pretty interesting
and then someone that runs a big website
comes and says look we took all of our
traffic data puts it put it in here and
we can tell you which are efficient
channels which are inefficient channels
and so it takes this very technical
thing and it creates and it puts in the
context of someone who has created a ton
of value and in every instance economic
value right this is unambiguous I saved
money I made the system stay up longer I
you know extracted costs etc and then
what's better someone is up in the front
of the in front of the audience who is
representing that this has happened who
isn't from your company right they're
saying here is how this has helped my
company
made me a hero in my organization and so
it's you know it's the you to could be a
hero you know if you all you need to do
is use Splunk and you could be a hero
within your organization it's been great
for me it could be great for you that is
unbelievably powerful and actually I
have I am a very firm believer now in in
using the your customers as your
evangelist for and in any instance that
you can and I say this at board meetings
all the time people are tired of it yes
we know David you might need to tell a
story
I think Skype is also done a great job
of starting to really tell the story and
it's not that they're telling the story
to your point right they're just sharing
it they're just providing the platform
so that customers could could do exactly
what they're doing anyways but in a
larger format yeah so I have another one
just a quick one but I have a company
that I invested in called pay near me
yeah pay near me is essentially allows
you to pay cash for things that you
otherwise would use a credit card for or
write a check and it turns out that 25
percent of the United States does not
have a bank account does not have a
credit card and so the way that they
have to deal with pit transactions
paying bills etc is to show up and hand
over cash it's incredibly inefficient
and so what we've learned and pay near
me by allowing you to to pay cash at a
7-eleven that's next door to you to pay
your bills or to buy something online is
that people who otherwise would stand an
hour for four six hours with the same
group of people who all need to pay
their their rent on a Friday now can go
six minutes away not stand in line pay
in two minutes and move on with their
lives right so they have the the
convenience that those of us with credit
cards and checking and checking accounts
all have because of this infrastructure
that's been built to empower them and I
think that that's really you know that's
what the story is about it's not about
financial transactions it's about people
who have a really inconvenient life
because they haven't been in power
yeah and then they're transformed and I
think that speaks really well to this
fourth story this idea of why is this
idea huge and you could think about this
as your innovation or growth story so
you can have a great founding story that
brings in a great team you could be
telling your customers story extremely
well or at least sharing it on your
platform
or other platforms and yet when you want
to start growing and scaling and it
might be global and maybe from you know
a digital perspective you need to have
another story and that is why is this
huge why should you know everyone kind
of come along for the ride and I think
Square is a fantastic example of this
maybe you could speak to that for a
little bit just the idea of empowering
millions of small business owners who
don't have the capacity I mean you know
they're all all these instances in which
which technology has made things
possible for the small business that
before was not possible right right and
so in the in the micro you look at it
and go well it's a small transaction
it's a small amount of money and so why
does anyone care but in the macro you
look and say there are millions of small
business owners who who are looking to
be empowered and so in this instance
it's the it's the millions of people who
are driving a taxi or selling at an Art
Fair or have a business in their home
etc who literally have the distant
disadvantage of not being able to do
online transactions not being able to
take credit and credit cards etc and
suddenly are empowered because they have
a device in their pocket that has the
processing power and they have a network
that's been built to take out the cost
and take out the friction and so it's
empowering this so you'd say well in
this in the smallest sense every
customer is worth a very small amount of
money but in the aggregate the customers
are massive billions of dollars in
transactions and so so figuring out a
bridge that gap is really exciting
absolutely and I think that that this
idea of being really human centered
staying really focused on that one
individual even though that that
transaction is so small but it's staying
so human centered what is it that they
need and then allowing the
audience that's listening to your story
make the inference about the potential
growth so I wanted to kind of bring us
to a sort of a larger platform to pose
for big big questions to you and then
what I think we'll do is is is just you
know conclude with maybe a few of your
favorite tips and tricks and also take
some Q&A those four questions are how do
you use sternal how I was using stories
internally within an organization
important I know we talked in chapter
two about this idea that stories can be
used to build a strong team but there's
other there there's other reasons why
stories internally are really important
the second is how can storytelling play
a role in a turnaround situation the
third is what elements does a story need
to be compelling this is more tactical
question and the fourth and and final
would just be how our story's proven
mechanisms to spur action and consumers
so are any of those four stories at all
sort of jump-started by by an anecdote
or two sure no I mean you know so this
question of story and stories being
internally important I mean you and I
have often talked about this that the
idea that story is really about
emotional connection right and people
people often think oh this is this kind
of squishy thing and it does what role
does that play in business and yet it
plays a plays a role in every instance
and why are people motivated how do they
stay engaged etc and so in Silicon
Valley right now it is incredibly
competitive to get employees you
actually to try and hire people into
your organization is one of the largest
challenges for for a company that's
doing well or we're selling lots of
things we have lots of opportunity we
just need more people turns out that
that's a massive challenge so this
emotional connection how do you engage
your future employees your current
employees to love what they're doing to
be engaged in what they're doing turns
out to be immensely important and I was
at an organizational meeting the other
day where we were talking about the
value that one of the pieces of secret
sauce of this company was keeping people
which seems absurd like Oh keeping your
employees this is some big piece of
secret sauce but it turns out the way
they manage their employee base to keep
the ones who knew what they were doing
around was was as important as trying to
figure out how to bring new people in
right so so so in from a story
standpoint I'll tell you something that
I'm obsessed with I've blogged about it
on my blog I've tweeted about it and
that is t-shirts I am obsessed with
company t-shirts I think that company
t-shirts are unbelievably powerful and
valuable and and in the early days of
Yahoo and then you'd see this as well
even to this day in Google if you went
to the office and you walked around
every other person was wearing a yahoo
t-shirt a Google t-shirt it's an amazing
thing and it's a powerful thing but the
t-shirts have a message right and so so
so when I look at companies that and
they don't yet have company t-shirts I
say you need a t-shirt you know and they
say David is this really a topic for the
board as absolutely you don't understand
the power of and it's always telling the
story so you know for Google and
organizing the world's information or or
don't be evil whether it was Splunk
which has these great t-shirts you'll
see them all over the place you know
their most famous t-shirt made a very
lena very clear made very clear what
they did their t-shirt said Splunk
tastes taking the SH out of IT all right
there you have it it turns out that
information technology is an has moments
where you have a problem these guys
solve it right unbelievably compelling
story in a in a t-shirt right and so I
think that every great company should be
able to sum up their what is compelling
and engaging about their organization
and what they're doing in a shirt and
they everybody should be wearing ah I
love that idea
you're not Ferrari which is all about a
story right no marketing budget it is
the story
employees wear red uniforms and they're
so connected to these red uniforms that
they wear
that a everyone wears them and they wear
them after work so they don't take the
uniform off and leave it at work they go
home and the community sees them and
they're so proud about what that means
so I would encourage not just t-shirts
but think about a uniform
own a color the color helps tell the
story as well yeah what about the role
of story and turnaround situations you
got a team you got a company they're not
doing well how do you use story to to
move that well I have one company where
it was the whole company it turns out
that it was the story it was an
understand completely the business that
shifted right and and and it's because
this was a company that was a consumer
business it was what you had millions of
consumers who were coming to to their
website and using that using the website
but the reality was that they were also
serving a set of e-commerce companies
right that they were that they were
empowering ecommerce you know sales
through their website and so from for
years they thought of the consumers as
their customers oh we have all these
consumers and we're trying to help them
you know we're trying to help them get
good good deals on buying experiences
etc and a new CEO came in and he looked
at the business they said you know what
consumers are gonna get great deals but
our customers are actually these these
online e-commerce companies right they
are the ones we're trying to help find
the cust connect with customers bring in
the right customer etc and so so he
changed the story the story was
empowering our partners our e-commerce
partners to be successful with their
customers and it changed everything
completely changed the trajectory in the
business completely changed how people
viewed their business how they viewed
what their goal was their goal was to
make the you know the the ecommerce
sites successful and the byproduct was
happy consumers who were spending more
and then the company was making more
money yeah a great example um
this idea of what elements does a story
need to be compelling I mean just based
on the stories that we shared in these
last 45 minutes you need to have a
protagonist
that goal right why are you telling the
story in the first place you need the
protagonist who is the person that the
audience is anchoring on and characters
around that protagonist not dissimilar
to Shakespeare the third is you need to
have a hook you know I understand why
would an audience even listen to you for
for a short period of time or a long
period of time and you really want a
fourth piece but for a fourth piece
which is what do you want the audience
to do after they hear this story so
rarely do we think about what do we want
that audience member to do so I would
say those are four incredibly important
elements of a good story
what would you add no I think those are
those are great I mean you know I
before becoming a venture capitalist I
was a litigator and so you know it turns
out that litigation is all about story
every year you're trying to convince the
courts or a jury or a set of arbitrators
that you're right and and back to our
earlier point about 2+2 you know you
don't tell them for you give them the
two and you give them the two and you
let them then figure out what the answer
is and so it's exactly that there's a
challenge you have a protagonist you
give them the resources to solve that
problem you drive them down a very clear
path and then you let them come to that
conclusion right there's an incredible
example here in America of this where
and it's astonishing this must be taught
now in every Law School in the in the in
the world but the OJ Simpson trial where
ultimately it was if the glove fits you
must acquit if you never ask a question
you don't know the answer to right and
so if they had just said here it is and
here's the you know
and here's here is his glove and here's
his hand and ba ba ba and never had him
put it on everyone sitting in the jury
and the ED would have said it's clearly
his glove by giving him the opportunity
to then block that and say oh it doesn't
fit you know boom destroyed the story
the story is here a set of pieces of
information here is the logical
conclusion and you yourself are so
emotionally connected to it that you
have to make a choice and that's true in
selling products it's true in litigation
it's true in motivating tea
on the sidelines we we have a mutual
friend who's a was an NFL football
player tells the tale of a coach and the
coach does the same thing right it is
here's our here's the here where the we
are the protagonists the antagonists are
clear
here is our tale and we are empowering
you to go tell your own epic tale of the
battle we're about to fight right it's
always the same and it's always
compelling absolutely and I think that
that's a great concluding point we could
take some questions but this idea that
when stories are so compelling that it
it touches not just employees but also
customers and then and makes customers
your advocate that's that's when you
know you have something incredibly
powerful so I'm not note what we'd like
to do is open it up for QA we're also
going to be posting many of the slides
that we used for this webinar along with
some tips and tricks that we like on to
SlideShare so we'll share that with a
with the team so there are a couple of
questions that I've seen one of them is
how can you create a compelling personal
story what are the what are the maybe
quick things that I need you think about
to capture an audience right away this
is Paul Marco by the way great so one
exercise you can do is simply write down
you know David and I started off with a
six word story about each of us go back
through your life you know ever you know
when you were 10 years old 15 years old
20 years old
etc and just write down the six word
story that defines your life at that
time and you start to look and say what
are the common threads among each of
those stories and now we'll actually you
know it takes two minutes to do that
exercise and it's incredibly informative
to figure out how you're not only what
your core story is what are the themes
across each of those very short stories
but also where you're going in the
future because I think what people think
is that they have one story they are
this one person as this one story that's
going to create this one legacy and
that's not true the reality is is that
we're made up of different stories and
we have research to show that our
meaning of happiness shifts in
in very systematic ways every sort of
five five years or so and with that
comes a story that we're living these
different chapters of this overarching
story so that I would say is a very easy
to do tip to figure out not just what
your larger narrative is but what are
the micro stories that have defined your
life to date and inform where you're
going and just one quick one quick point
which is people are often ignored their
own internal motivations they think that
there has to be some external
explanation but the reality is
oftentimes the most compelling thing is
why did you do this right people don't
think that the why matters but the why
really matters in your story why is it
you chose to go to school here why did
you choose to start this business why
have you become an accountant though the
why matters in your story that I mean
just a build on that point you know we
spent both for business perspective and
a personal perspective we spend so much
time on the wet and the how as
differentiators right what we're doing
is different how we're doing it is
different but to your point when you
nail the why you're doing it is
different and that all coheres you have
something really powerful and that
applies to people as it does for brands
you